this was your last trip out in the
minibus yeah
a vaccine that protects those who need
it the most would be a game changer for
care homes
for six months jan was denied close
contact with her mum
weekly covert testing at gracewell of
newbury has allowed more normal visits
during the second wave
but new results showing the fisa vaccine
is more than
94 effective in people over 65
has given her hope it would be
absolutely
amazing to have had that vaccine and to
be able to come in
as normal at any time of the day in the
evening
whenever you feel like coming because
it's always been open house
full analysis of the trials of the fisa
vaccine show it's 95 percent effective
even better than have been previously
thought from interim results
of 170 cases of coveted in the studies
just
eight were in people who'd had two doses
of the vaccine
there were no major side effects but
some people reported fatigue and a
headache
that many scientists jeffrey armand is a
vaccine expert and formerly head of
research and development for another
major pharmaceutical company
we don't expect vaccines to work quite
this well in the elderly
normally they're less good in the
elderly than the general population
so to have something that's indicating
90 plus percent
is a really exciting result if this
vaccine works really well to prevent
all severe disease in whatever age group
then obviously that takes a lot of
pressure off the health service
means that it can start working properly
again
pfizer says it will apply to u.s
regulatory authorities for emergency use
authorization
within a matter of days uk authorities
have already begun assessing the data
rollout of the vaccine could then follow
with 10 million doses available here by
the end of the year
it's the questions over how long
protection lasts for
and does it also stop transmission and
we won't know that
really for some weeks and months as we
wait and watch how the vaccine
behaves over time it is the distribution
of the vaccine that could prove the
biggest challenge
it needs to be kept at -70 well beyond
the temperature of a conventional
freezer
but pfizer has designed special
packaging with dry ice
and is confident that the vaccine will
remain active from factory
all the way to the clinic thomas more
sky news